when Cole Morris was two years old he
broke his thigh bone on the dance floor
at a wedding he's got a cast that goes
from here all the way down to the end of
one of his legs and partway down another
leg and he was still in diapers so they
had to cut a hole in it and we had to
put the date it was terrible
his treatment ultimately cost about
$13,000 but Jason Morris his wife Tina
and their six kids don't have health
insurance
instead they belong to Samaritan
ministries an organization of devout
Christians the chip in to cover each
other's medical bills Samaritan members
from all over the country mailed them
small checks until they had accumulated
enough to pay all their bills so in
essence that huge traumatic experience
with my son we had the emotional side of
it but the financial side of it was
completely taken care of through other
people sending his checks for the for
the for the total Mountain Samaritan is
headquartered in Peoria Illinois where
94 staffers work to coordinate the bill
sharing process it requires that its
members send 370 dollars each month to
another family to help pay for a medical
need the organization has about 86,000
members spread among all 50 states which
makes it the largest of three so-called
health care sharing ministries in the US
the philosophy is that patients are
ultimately responsible for their own
medical bills but in times of crisis the
larger community comes together to help
carry the burden when I send my check I
usually stick a little sticky note on
there or a card that says hey you know
Bob I'm praying for you this month and
hope you're doing well and pray you have
that you'd be completely healed and
whole again and you recognize that you
know every dollar I said is gonna go
help that person who's experiencing that
crisis right now there's some real
satisfaction in that Samaritan will
probably soon become a thing of the past
a casualty of Obamacare and it's likely
fate is just one example of how the new
law is further eroding the sort of
personal engagement that the healthcare
industry desperately needs the reason
Samaritans in trouble is simple it will
have to compete with plans and the new
health care exchanges that are also
tailored to people who don't get
insurance through their jobs but the
deck is stacked for most Samaritan
members buying insurance on the
exchanges will be much cheaper
thanks to massive taxpayer subsidies
take the
average Samaritan households which has
three members and an annual income of
about $40,000 under Obamacare that
family will pay somewhere around twenty
five hundred dollars per year to buy a
standard policy on the new health care
exchanges why so cheap because for a
family at this income level federal tax
payers will pick up about two-thirds of
the total cost of the insurance policy
compare that twenty five hundred dollar
price tag to the cost of an annual
membership in Samaritan and thanks to
taxpayers the average family will pay in
the neighborhood of two thousand dollars
per year for quitting Samaritan and
signing up for a subsidized insurance
plan with richer benefits overall
Samaritan members have incomes low
enough that about 90 percent of them
will be eligible for federal subsidies
what ties us together is not our desire
to get our health care bills man James
Lansbury who Samaritans executive vice
president says most members will stick
with the organization regardless this is
part of who we are as part of our DNA is
the Christian Church and instead of
wanting to be a part of an insurance
company when I joined I wanted to be a
part of something where the body of
Christ was actually banding together and
doing what the Bible commanded in a more
personal and real way and Samaritan
ministries was a great example of that
and I wouldn't want to do anything else
for my own health care but it would
hardly be the first time that a new
government entitlement destroyed a
voluntary organization built around
commonly held beliefs in a sense
Samaritan is one of the last Mutual Aid
Societies organizations that once played
an integral role in American life they
were geared towards providing temporary
help to those unlucky enough to lose a
job or get sick without creating
permanent dependency mutual aid
societies started disappearing with the
rise of government programs like welfare
Medicaid food stamps and unemployment
insurance
subsidized health insurance plans
through Obamacare certainly provide
richer benefits that they do away with
incentives that over time are the key to
driving down prices and driving up
quality for example under the standard
plan on the health care exchanges when
patients go to the doctor they're
responsible for no more than forty-five
dollars out-of-pocket an insurance pays
the rest Samaritan members would
generally pay the entire bill
out-of-pocket because they can only ask
other members to cover bills that exceed
$300 absolutely we hold out longer than
somebody who has an insurance plan and
will just you know do the five dollar
copay or whatever because we know it's
gonna cost us I don't really see that as
a problem I actually see it as a good
thing it's kind of like I hope it's not
too crass to compare it to waiting for
the sale at Menards you know you don't
buy the front door when they're hundred
and forty you be buying when they're on
sale for hundred under Obamacare
patients can get a whole range of
preventive services and pay nothing out
of pocket when Samaritan members get the
same procedures they have to pay the
entire bill themselves now if you're a
doctor and you know the patient who you
have to look in the eye you will never
have to pay a single penny of the cost
of a colonoscopy or a mammogram or pap
smear you're gonna try to bridge her
price because there's no reason not to
Samaritan is designs that its members
actually care about what things cost
Roger's Stuber who belongs to Samaritan
and works as a residential contractor in
Tremont Illinois has gone to extreme
lengths to save money for his fellow
members he had brain surgery last year
to repair a leaky vein in the right side
of his head a pool of blood right in
this area of my brain the hospital
initially was gonna charge him more than
63 thousand dollars for his surgery even
though he'd be reimbursed by other
members he negotiated the bill down to
just over $36,000 when he was billed
$5,000 for a follow-up MRI at first the
hospital refused to offer him much of a
discount so I finally looked up where
their financial department was drove out
to their finance offices sat down and
wanted to speak to the lady in charge
the hospital eventually agreed to accept
just under $1,500 if Stuber would pay
cash on the spot I'm part of a body
there at Samaritan
if I can keep costs down I'm helping the
group it's the sort of effort that no
patient covered by one of Obamacare's
health plans would ever bother with
whatever the fate of Samaritan
ministries the growing role of
government in the sector is taking away
the power of individuals to make
healthcare cheaper and better